boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sockin very
excited to be talking about the long now
we have Xander Rose joining us on the
show hello hello thank you so much for
coming on really appreciate it
very grateful for you coming on there's
a lot that we're gonna talk about in
subsidise that don't know Xander Rose
Alexander Xander Rose is the executive
director of the long now foundation and
the founder curator of the interval
they have facilitated projects such as
the 10,000 year clock the Rosetta
project long bets seminars about long
term thinking long server and others
Alexander shares several design paths on
the 10,000 year clock with Danny Hillis
the first prototype of which is in the
Science Museum of London and the
monument scale version is now under
construction in West Texas you can find
the links in the bio below too long now
org as well as the interval dot org and
also the Twitter too long now and
Xander's Twitter as well so alright
Xander let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world well I think you
know people are rightly concerned around
things like climate change and and
obviously some of that economic and
power shifts that are happening right
now but I think I think those are
actually while climate change is gonna
play out over a long period of time I
suspect the demographic changes that are
happening right now are going to have an
even larger effect so somewhere in the
next 50 years world population is going
to peak and I think if we're actually
gonna do better to adapting to something
like climate change than we are going to
adapt to a world of a declining
population where the age pyramid of
mostly young people getting to older
people is also inverting so you know you
look at a country like Japan that this
has already happened to when that
happens to the entire developed world
it's going and developing world it's
that I think is going to be one of the
larger ships that has happened in the
last 10,000 years actually the
inclination to want to procreate
decrease with the software eating the
world artificial intelligence robotics
all these things happening and yeah
that's a really good point that many of
us are not thinking about in the long
now and this long-term thinking
perspective I like that answer a lot all
right let's jump into the journey
because we have so many cool images as
we're gonna be unpacking along now I
want to get to that you were born in
Paris but then you moved on you're one
to the Bay Area to South cielito where
you're growing up you went to Carnegie
Mellon in Pittsburgh in the design
school then you came back and who were
you growing up how did you get
interested in the fields that you cared
about well I
to be fair I never was interested in
clock building until projects but I was
always interested in building things I
grew up in this old shipyard junkyard on
the the older Sausalito waterfront and
it was it was a place where you could
always build anything you know catapults
and forts and all kinds of stuff and I
was always doing that and so I thought
that I wanted to be an inventor and
there is no inventor school and so the
closest thing is product design and I
ended up going to Carnegie Mellon came
back and mostly was doing a lot of
digital design work because that was
what the lot of the work was in the mid
90s and still today but growing up I
also knew Stewart Brand who was one of
the founders of long now and he had just
kind of in just barely incorporated it
as a nonprofit didn't have any staff yet
and I was talking with him and he told
me about this clock project and at that
time it wasn't a larger foundation it
really just was this idea to build this
10,000 year clock to change the way
people think about time and
and I went on a lunch a lot of other
interviews but I couldn't get this one
out of my head I was like well I have to
you know figure out what this means and
and so then I started down the path of
working on the first prototype and then
eventually it became a much larger
project it became a lifelong career
endeavor for you 23 years since 97
building putting this together okay I
think it's good to jump into the assets
that we have now and Ronnie will be
bringing them up as we go through them
this quote really resonated with me
Richard Fineman quote we are at the very
beginning of time for the human race it
is not unreasonable that we grapple with
problems but there are tens of thousands
of years in the future our
responsibility is to do what we can
learn what we can improve the solutions
and pass them on and then on the next
asset these are the types of things that
I think that when you started explaining
this to me I can see how you got hooked
into the long now perspective of
thinking I think and we could have
started the episode with this thought
but just we're so stuck in our 10 20 30
50 year life time periods that it's
really hard for us to go back and see
the hundred billion humans that built
civilization it's hard for us to go
forward ten thousand years to see where
civilization is going but to do that to
unlock ourselves from our biological
constraint I'm period is so important it
gives us the reasoning that we need in
order to have what I think is a vaccine
to ignorance potentially his big history
and big future and this example the walk
us through the New College Oxford
example of long now thinking well this
is this is a story that is one of the
kind of origin stories of lone now it
was originally it was told by Gregory
Bateson just to her friends her friend
told it to Danny Hillis and Teddy houses
the computer designer out of MIT was
sending some of the fastest
supercomputers and his whole life people
had asked him to build faster and faster
and faster things and when Stewart told
him this story it kind of clicked that
when they built this this the main hall
at new college which was new in the
1200s they used these giant oak beams
that that they could get at that time
and then five hundred years later these
beams needed to be replaced and you all
of a sudden you couldn't get these in
Europe anymore and this is 1,200 this is
now 1800s five hundred years later and
they weren't commercially available and
it wasn't till they spoke to the school
Forester said oh we have the trees that
you planted and this notion that a
simple act of scattering some acorns in
the ground but even more important act
of actually keeping the cultural memory
around that you knew to use them to then
solve a totally intractable problem with
leveraging longevity in this kind of
profound way it was something that you
know Danny realized that it's not
something that was a regular occurrence
and that you know we kind of we wish
that our ancestors would have cared
enough to plant the acorns and so what
are the acorns that we could be planting
now for those people five hundred years
or a thousand years from now and that
was really the kind of this bit that
gets flipped is like as soon as you
start thinking okay well actually we are
going to be around in a thousand years
in ten thousand years humans are a very
tenacious species and as much doom and
gloom as we hear from you know about the
future it's actually things have been
getting better for the last ten thousand
years on average generation by
generation and there's nothing to say
that that we can't keep that going or at
the very least we can make decisions
that make that better and our do are we
operating that way now or not is an
interesting question
wow what a corns were with the foresight
to be planting the acorns third and 1300
for 1800 and then and then also what are
the acorns now that need to be planted
for 500 years I think a lot of it has to
do potentially with the spiritual and
ethical growth of us as humans and if we
can plant those acorns now it will make
the future a lot eat more smooth yeah I
think one of the things that we've
learned is we've kind of played in this
space is that fundamentally if you're
making decisions that open up choices
for the future you generally that's
generally a good thing like we are happy
when that has happened in our own past
but when you're making choices that that
decrease the scope of what the future
can choose from that generally makes
future generations less happy and I
think it's a kind of a fundamental
simple principle but it's a it's it's
pretty powerful this idea an example I
often give is you look at something like
that the Bill of Rights which was you
know ten things with couple sentences
each but they're all principle based
words and they assumed that every
generation would reinterpret them and
you look at a modern law that's a
thousand pages long and it's entire
every single word of that is devoted to
making sure the future cannot interpret
it differently than the present and that
just seems like a silly idea right like
the future always has better information
than us they have they have much more
understanding of the concerns that
matter in their present time we should
trust them why don't we trust them and
so I think trying to find more ways to
trust the future is a is a interesting
task that we all can exercise yeah it's
um it's also kind of like what are the
updates in in civilizations code in 500
years that will be present and how can
we help make those updates more feasible
now what actions can we take yeah also
like things like the 50 like in 50 years
there'll be the the kids that look back
at us and say I can't believe you're
slaughtering billions
and like now we have clean meat it's
like these types of things how can we
yeah yeah that I love that thinking and
okay so the next slide is you mentioned
this a little bit ago but that it's you
and when we will move on with it with
wrong that um Danny Hillis Stuart brand
Brian is you know you know and then a
bunch of the other and this is this is
kind of the piece this is this is like
the team behind this is the board now i
think i think that's updated it's closed
up today but I think we actually just
added another board member
Patrick Collison of stripe actually oh
yeah but it's not sly it's not quite up
today but yeah I was people like Kevin
Kelly was the founding editor at Wired
you know and Esther Dyson who over say
from released to 1.0 and 2.0 and the
conferences that she did Paul Safa who's
who is the longtime director of the
Institute for the future Peter Schwartz
who were at art of long he was all these
people who were both embedded in the
kind of early generation of Silicon
Valley and the very forefront of the of
when tech really started to take off and
I think in a way they were kind of these
Canaries and the coal mine of seeing the
fetishizing of speed only and and that
if it can't be done fast we're not even
gonna try and and that that I think they
realized that there needed to be some
kind of counterpoint to that and and
that was something that was really
important with Stu Stuart brand who've
been you've been kind of hacking culture
since the 60s with the Whole Earth
Catalog and and then did you know the
was instrumental and the personal
computer kind of taking a turn away from
industry and defense towards being a
truly personal thing that that people
used for for a much more interesting
purposes than just corporate and defense
purposes so it was that group that I
think they had an early set of
antibodies that made them raise their
hands and say okay well some problems
like something like climate change for
instance if you're only given one year
to solve it you're not even gonna try
but if you were given several hundred
years to solve it you could imagine how
you might start doing something
that and if we don't put the longer
timescale on the table then we don't
even get to try yeah yeah it's great to
have that counter measure like you said
on the Silicon Valley microprocessor is
go go fast SS versus to slow down and
think ten thousand year time scale and
that this helps the when you give images
like this it gets people to to think
about how big the universe is and how
big our galaxy is and how big our solar
system is and how important it is for us
to think about things in these
timescales yeah and and one of the early
parts of the project was you know okay
well so Denny envisioned this thing it
was a clock that would tick once a year
and bung once a century and the cuckoo
would come out once a millennium and he
called it the millennium clocking wrote
it up in an essay that resonated with
this group of friends and then it was
published way back in the 95 of wired
and you know some people thought he was
crazy why is this computer scientists
talking about building the slowest
computer in the world and it was and
part of that discussion came around a
sec ok well it's a if it's a millennium
clock it's not just ticking off
millennia forever like what is our
design life what are we actually talking
about for the time scale and when you
look at something like you know billions
of years of astronomic time it's so
drawer f---ing to the human experience
that it's hard to feel any
responsibility in that and if you you
know if you then scale it a little bit
more down to earth of you know geologic
time scale of millions of years you know
the 13 million years it took the Grand
Canyon to to be you know itched into the
earth that's still pretty dwarfing to
our experience but if you get down to
ten thousand years and not just the last
ten thousand years but the last and the
next 10,000 years you see and you start
to see yourself and the human story is
not the end of a ten thousand year story
but the middle of a twenty thousand year
story and so you have this past in this
future that you're dealing with I think
that's that's really where the long now
finds its sweet spot is
okay well the last ten thousand years
when less ice age were treated and
agriculture started in cities bringing
up these assets
as we're going cities started yes so
this was the green and then the next one
is kind of what I'm talking about
right now yeah that this is kind of the
Anthropocene moment this is when you
know 8000 BC is really where we start to
see civilizations starting to flourish
all around the world and so the idea is
that that's that's the right amount for
the law now and if you divided that up
at 25 year generations that would be 400
generations and we don't know what how
long generations will really be in the
future but you know we can you might
imagine how you could tell a story that
got handed down 400 times right and
that's that that that starts to feel
tractable in a way but also stretches
obviously beyond any current institution
or organization that we know of
yeah to take ourselves out of what today
is like yesterday today tomorrow - oh my
generation of these last 30 years this
decade last decade next decade and
versus the all of since the first like
modern day agriculture all from from
initial agriculture all the way up to
the exponential technology age that sort
of view and ten thousand years from now
I think this is one of the most
important ways to view our world is in
this macro big history big future
perspective yeah I mean and I think and
this is actually one of the very first
things I did that long I was working
with both Brian Eno and Stuart brand and
they were trying to kind of tease apart
what are the layers of human time and
and how do we know when something is
being done well in the long term
thinking space or not and you know out
here on the the very outside layers
you've got the fashion and art and you
know I think even communications
technology if it's in this now of like
very frenetic very fast and as you drop
down through commerce and infrastructure
and governance and culture and at the
very bottom moving the slowest and
batting last is nature right and
and it's a it's a good way to kind of
govern how decisions are made and so for
instance you know if you're cutting down
old-growth redwoods because you want to
make a bunch of money off them up here
on this Commerce scale but you're you
know you're doing something that's that
can't be replaced on that scale yes and
you're working on this nature schedule
Ike you've skipped all of these things
and you and when companies have done
that then they you know culture gets
involved and says hold on wait a minute
we don't want you to just commercialize
this you know slow we're growing natural
asset and then governance gets involved
and makes laws and so it you know that's
when when you share those layers in a
bad way
that's when you know all of a sudden
people start going or this isn't right
we need to fix it or you know things get
destroyed in perpetuity that we don't
ever get to have back and it goes back
to that thing of like you know if you're
if you're cutting down those trees no
future generation gets to enjoy them or
make any decisions about them you and
you've now taken options away from those
future generations
so that's again you should have been
creating those options yes people yeah
how do we realize that in the commerce
time period that people are self-dealing
themselves in the short-term 30 year
windows but really to look at it on an
on a longer time scale yeah yeah that's
yeah and I think you know there's there
are things that should happen fast I
mean there's it's there's great
experimentation that should happen if
you're if you're always aware of how
everybody failed before you you might
not try crazy interesting things like
there's you know there's there's an
argument for the move fast break things
kind of various world and and there's
and but I think you should you know the
the idea of long now is that there
should also be some a check where you're
like okay there's some things we can
move fast and break but there's some
things like you know basic levels of
culture and history that we should make
sure that we at least have in a safe
room while we're breaking some other
things over here yeah and so what are
those you know trying to identify what
those things are how we might focus on
them how you might contextualize the
work that you're doing in the short term
that is moving the needle to what you
need to do every day and every week but
also is that in an arc that's helpful
for the longer term for you for human
or are you you know are you cutting down
old-growth redwoods just to make a buck
how do we get them as inclusive
stakeholders to future generations and
also the environment as an inclusive
stakeholder the this is you set a clock
that was recovered from the bottom of
the ocean yeah it's it's a kind of
famous story called the it's called the
Antikythera device because of where I
was found off of the coast of
Antikythera Greece and no one really
understood its significance when they
pulled it up out of this wreck for
decades and finally when they did some
they started pulling it apart with
x-rays they realized that it was a very
it was parts of a very intricate clock
and it interesting things about it
mechanically were that it set back the
date that we thought for instance people
knew about differential gearing by 1500
years and it's very likely it was coming
from the the Arab world to the Greek
world and there's never been an object
found like it and it but it was
effectively was an astronomical not so
much a clock but a like a and like an
orrery or an armillary that would show
you things like eclipses and lunar
cycles and planets cycles so in a way
was clock was kind of clockwork universe
that air and the it showed an early
lesson for us if we're if if we're going
to do something like make a ten thousand
year clock that changes the way people
think about time if we were just to make
a digital clock a it doesn't have much
drama to it and be it it doesn't
it doesn't self document so if you were
to find pieces of it if you find it
we're not working it's very difficult to
understand the intent of the people that
that built it and what it was about so
this idea of okay well if we're gonna
try and get people to think about longer
term make an icon to long term thinking
a kind of monument scale ten thousand
year clock it should be mechanical it
should be big enough that you experience
it in a way like going to the Grand
Canyon where you it's visceral it's big
enough that you're walking through it
and that's that's how this kind of this
project that I got going was that idea
and to not lose artifacts like that
before the sands of time just dust turn
them into dust but in order for us to
actually take them and understand how
civilization got to where it is the next
the next slide is also is this also
another part well that's that's a
recreation of the Antikythera device and
with modern technology okay and the
other two before that were also parts of
it yeah these were the actual fragments
that were found okay those were the
actual fragments okay cool we are on
showed those I saw okay and then this is
one more time this was that's a
recreation of what it was a recreation
of what it was yeah because several
people have done various oh okay okay
and then what's this guy well I think so
some of these are strategies for how
things have lasted over time and so I've
been collecting these stories over the
last twenty plus years and one that's a
curious one to me is this idea of
sacrifice or an ablative layer and and
we see it in nature with something like
a lizard that can you know a bird can
attack it and they can take the tail
away and think and the bird thinks it's
now one and but the lizard grows the
tail again and goes on to live another
day and we see things in antiquity like
the pyramids and a lot of the Egyptian
sites or the Taj Mahal where a lot of
the value is extracted out by robbers
but actually there's a ton of value
still left in the paintings on the walls
and the structures themselves the Taj
Mahal was crusted with jewels through
the entire thing and instead of being
destroyed they spent a lot of time
prying all the jewels out
English eventually and and no and that's
the structure survives right so it
becomes this interesting thing if you
have a high value layer that people
think they can extract a value out of
and don't end up destroying the actual
structure and the fundamentals of it so
it's a it's it's a principle that I
don't know much how to do much with but
I think it's an interesting one where we
see it's happened time and time again Oh
throughout history mm-hmm this
interesting principle I should bring up
there okay and then you gave us the
example with the pyramids and that's the
next slide that that people would Rob
like the interiors rather like saying
the thing with the Taj Mahal
so rather than like desecrating the
exterior it'd be to get the jewels from
the interior okay and then the next
asset is the the seed vault yes this
when I heard about this and I heard this
announced I was really intrigued that
they were trying to build this
thousand-year seed vault and it has a
very interesting and sorted history this
is Norway it's sort of its a Norwegian
Protectorate it's in a place called
Svalbard which is the northernmost
continuously had inhabited place on
planet and it's since 78 degrees north
but you can't actually fly commercially
into it actually I think the next slide
has the airport what the airport looks
like Airport as you're about to land
which is one landing strip that's the
landing strip and this is actually the
sea boat right here yeah it's right next
to it but this an idea of remoteness was
very interesting to me because we had
decided to make the clock in a very
remote site so that the our notion was
that you know a it's out of the fray of
cities that tend to get involved in Wars
or have accidents and all kinds of
things but it also it means that you
have this intentionality of going to the
site and that you have to spend time
with the group of people you're going
with that's right thinking about it you
go through the experience you then
hopefully are changed and then you spend
the time traveling back like reflecting
on that experience and by the remoteness
kind of creates this journey aspect to
it that I think is pretty important
Vernon is just a selfie grab it in the
city and get out right that's a you know
that's kind of drive by experience that
that you get and I think the the other
thing that it creates is a level of
mystique because not everyone is going
to get there you have to really set
aside time and make a trip to do it that
it's kind of more powerful in the kind
of mythic sense then it would be as if
it was you know right in the city for
you to just access whenever you want it
okay inspire more people to get to it if
it's in a pop potentially population
centers maybe there can be recreated
versions of seed vaults and long now
clocks yeah actually that was an early
notion was the city clock and rural
clock and so right now we're building
this roll clock and we have these
prototypes places like the Science
Museum and even at our offices at the
interval here in San Francisco you can
see parts of the clock along the way but
you know I think if you go to the next
slide here there's I think a picture
that's the door as you go in there next
one door it looks like we're playing a
video game was that in the log book
which I I thought was amazing the people
that were ahead of me in this log book
and it was like bang ki-moon from the UN
and Jimmy Carter is like all these
delegations that have come to this
ridiculous place to look at a door yeah
they only open the door every six months
we happen to be there we schedule the
time to be there when they actually open
the door but like oh they only open it
twice a year yeah and so because they
don't want to add contaminants they
schedule all the seeds to go in at at
these two times a year and we weren't
guaranteed to even get in when we flew
all the way there and after talking to
them they they let us in but it's they
didn't design this whole thing around a
tour at all they didn't know that anyone
would be interested in it
and I think what's in what is
interesting is that it became this kind
of mythic thing that people hold in
their heads of oh well there's some
people in the world that are storing
seeds in case they're needed in the
future exam and that actually created a
lot of a mythic imagery for people and
and it's you know it's now it's it's
kind of part of the cultural story and
so we hope to be able to achieve with
the clock as well yeah yeah oh so
beautiful such a good comparison and do
we need more of these around the world
the seed vaults the law
clocks we need more of these around the
world and inspired long-term thinking
okay and this is more example so this is
sucker out of Amelia this particular one
is not which we have next slide is this
is a cathedral at Cologne Germany and
this and similar to the Cologne Germany
the place the the foam this was the
first story that I told it was started
in the twelve hundreds but in this case
it actually took six hundred years to
build it and I think one of the most
dangerous times for any institution even
or a company or a cultural organization
is that first generation after it was
started handing it off to one or two
generations after that is very dangerous
that's it that's when it's no longer the
cool new thing it's now the thing my
parents did it's not you know and when
here in San Francisco we saw you know a
time when all the Victorians were all
torn down because they weren't cool
anymore and then put up all these kind
of concrete monstrosity 's and now we've
realized that we wish we had you know
more of the cool Victorians and so that
you have to make it through this kind of
trough of unpopularity before something
becomes then valued for being old and
and all of that and so if you take
really long time to build it that's one
way to kind of look at that right you've
now crossed that threshold and something
like the Sagrada família which was
started over a hundred years ago and and
is now coming in to over 125 years in
construction but it's already a UNESCO
World Heritage Site and it's it's a
construction site like it's still being
built which I think is an amazing thing
that that it can be both a cultural site
and not done yeah and so it's crossed
that threshold anybody go through times
when nobody wanted to fund it and we
kind of had this murky future and now it
seems to be on a much better path so
it's a it's an interesting strategy if
you take if you go really slow as long
as you can kind of make it through that
trough and keep the energy interesting
and keep that I think in the case of
these cathedrals like there was always
an interesting problem to be solved and
people were engaged whereas if it was
just done in one year I don't know if
they would have
made it as far to keep it cool for the
kids in the future to want to keep it
around that's so critical mm-hmm it
major component of it okay cool and then
the next assets another one that's been
maintained what is this one these are
two of the oldest continuously standing
wooden structures in the world and
they're in a place in Japan outside of
Issei and they're in Japan is singular
in its ability to maintain things and
Kevin Kelly likes to like his pastime is
as you drive or take a train across
Japan to look for a single missing tile
on our roof and there's just not one
right like they're just so good at
maintaining so these you know the the
wooden structures that the wooden beams
in these structures have been there for
you know fourteen hundred years fourteen
hundred years yeah the wooden beams how
did they do that
yeah and it's a it's a nasty environment
for preservation it's like rainstorms
yeah it's hot and humid and but they've
just kept it maintained and they've
replaced little things but all the basic
structure has all been the same and I
think that I don't know if I'd the next
slide it's a shrine it's kind of a
different that's a different one but
there's a site next to that one called
Issei shrine where they've been
rebuilding the temples every 20 years
for for 1,600 years and it's in these
exact replicas and that's an interesting
one where you have this you know master
teaching the apprentice every generation
of you know here's how we do this and
why we do this and I think it helps the
Shinto belief system kind of remember
what it's about
and that this act of rebuilding is is an
interesting one yeah yeah for keeping
things relevant yeah
every 20 years for 1,600 years to read
reap rerai renovating yeah I was there
in 2013 for the 66th rebuilding
and it's a it's a it's an amazing that
yes 66 times 20 yeah it's it's a and
they have documentation of like how
they've done it well it's just it's a
astonishing that's preservation and this
is this again Seed Vault no this is
actually this is the last picture they
let me took take right before entering
the Mormon seed vault or the Mormon
genealogical vaults outside of Salt Lake
City and early on when I started this
project everyone is oh there's the
Mormon genealogical vaults and and and
then I would always ask whenever I found
connections to maybe get a tour and
there was never an answer and eventually
Stewart brand was asked to give a talk
at Brigham Young University and and we
were able to kind of couple it to a tour
of of the genealogical bolts and the
Mormons the Mormon Church back within
the Cold War got worried that their
genealogical records were going to be
destroyed
you know nuclear exchange and so they
built this amazing bunker that's it so
it's right off the left as you're going
towards some of the snow resorts and
outside of Salt Lake City in Little
Cottonwood Canyon these tunnels that go
back into the mountain and they're cross
the other way but you know in the Mormon
world they want to know all their their
ancestors so that they can baptize them
in the afterlife and so they're very
interested in keeping track of genealogy
but they've done you know aside from
doing things that religions often get
involved in all kinds of culture they
have become the record of all genealogic
genealogy for the world at least maybe
not that Muslim world so much as they
haven't really let them into their
archives but you know the reason all the
US censuses and things like that are
digitized it's because of these guys and
well and so there was another it was a
thousand year project where they they
tried to make you know they put it all
on microfiche they don't trust digital
technology and this is the inside this
is the inside yeah I found a picture of
the inside I didn't get to take a
picture of the inside for anything and
one of the stories that's that this is
about is that often when you're trying
to get things to last for a long time
places like where they're keeping you
clear waste or keeping things like this
underground does seem
a great idea except one of the problems
with underground is that you generally
lose on the water equation and that's
the next facet every single one of these
facilities that I've been to around the
world that tried to keep the water out
always failed and so really what you get
a choice of when you do underground is
you get a choice of where the water goes
you don't get a choice of whether or not
water is coming in and so this was the
pump that got installed at the Seed
Vault four years into its thousand year
design life the the the the genealogical
vault is flooded five or six times they
don't put anything in the bottom four
drawers because it splits floods and so
it definitely taught us a lesson if
we're gonna work underground that you
have to make things drain outward and
away from the things you care about you
know okay and then this is another the
next asset yeah this is actually from
kala this is a hundred thousand year
nuclear waste repository outside of
Helsinki Finland and and so yeah we have
these there's ten thousand year Yucca
Mountain project here in the United
States there's these hundred thousand
year repositories and more and more in
Europe this genealogical repositories
and they all have decided ultimately
that underground is where you're going
to preserve things and it's it's double
so for us with a clock because the the
thing that makes a clock inaccurate is
actually temperature swings and
underground you can stabilize the
temperature very simply so
and this is a the next slide yeah I
think this is the last in this kind of
series of lessons but this idea of
ideology and this is a before and after
picture of the Buddha's of Bamiyan and
Afghanistan and what happened
the Taliban spent weeks dynamiting these
amazing Buddhist sculptures I mean if
you look at the image how big a person
is in scale like these yeah these are
absolute wonders of the world yes and
and it's hard to imagine a more
innocuous really just symbol than a
Buddha and it was but it was still
ideologically worth it for them to spend
all this effort destroying these these
things and we've now seen this happen
you know in Palmyra and some of the
later things that have happened in the
Middle East are destroying these things
as an ideological thing and again it's
it's one I don't know how to really
handle because really long now in a way
isn't ideology it's saying that
long-term thinking is something that we
should pay attention to and you know how
do you how do you stop people who
actively want to destroy something you
really can't and I think the only way
you can do it that you have a shot at
doing is you it's not just designing the
object it's designing the institution
and the culture that it is part of that
keeps value and relevance to the current
culture yeah and I think things like
that noter downfall of fire are really
interesting in that sense where it's
kind of refocused everyone as like oh
this is actually a cultural asset that's
worth rebuilding and since it had enough
infrastructure and culture around it is
going to get rebuilt in some way right
and but you know the good is about me
out or not coming back
okay and that wraps that section and
then we get into the Rosetta project
which is one of the projects along with
the 10,000 year clock we'll get to the
10,000 your clock complexity this one it
really resonates with me how we have
developed communication tools like
language something like it was it eight
eight thousand total languages yeah
early on when Danny talked about this
idea of building a this millenium clock
Stuart brand was like okay well if we
get people attention around long term
thinking what do we do with it and he
had this thought of a of a library that
could last for 10,000 years and and
again it's the the parts of culture that
you don't want to lose over time and and
when we started looking at that we were
at the as the mid-90s and we're seeing
how the world was shifting everything
towards digital data and that that
digital data especially then and still
to the state to a large extent have
really has no forward migration path and
you know a thousand years ago we wrote
things on rocks and a hundred years ago
we wrote things on books and tens of
years ago we've been writing things in
computers and I guarantee you the things
on rocks in books we're gonna get but
the things that have been written on
computers really you don't know how
those things are going to survive we
don't have a good reason why they will
and so if we're going to store
information we realized the very first
thing that we needed to to do was
actually make a language key and the
rosetta stone is this great example from
history one of Napoleon's soldiers found
it again it wasn't understood for
decades after being found but it had two
languages and three different scripts
some of which we knew and that allowed
us to eventually after 50 year
deciphering effort the unlocking key to
hieroglyphics which we had masses
amounts of hieroglyphics in front of us
that we could not code right and so this
idea of how do you make a modern version
of that and if you move on to the next
one we spent over a decade collecting
different elements of thousands of
languages and then scanned them really
as images of pages and then micro etch
them with
my own beam into silicon and cast that
into a nickel plate that could last for
thousands of years and so instead of it
being ones and zeros it's actual pages
of information so you know in a way it's
like the microfiche that the the Mormons
are using but you can put it under a
microscope and you can read this
information it's not it's not dependent
on high technology just upticks
basically and this was an early
prototype that got launched on the
European Space Agency's Rosetta mission
and you can see some of the pages here
the next the final disc also had a side
of it that starts with eight different
world languages spiraling down smaller
and smaller that starts at him and I
readable scale and gets smaller and
smaller so it leads you into
understanding what it is and and then
hopefully all the data becomes useful so
it's you know preserving the language
doesn't mean you preserve meaning and it
doesn't mean you preserve culture but it
in the key in some cases when you're
talking about thousands of years of time
you sure would like a primer to help you
solve some of the basics and unlock so
if other things were preserved and like
in the case of hieroglyphics you want
something that helps you with that to be
able to preserve language and even like
culture at its most granular level over
time of evolution it's such an important
thing to do I think it's gonna help us a
lot when we're also running our own big
simulations and then being but they
analyze how civilizations evolved that
type of stuff okay and then what's up
with the next asset oh the the early
copy of the roads that I disc was
launched on the European Space Agency's
Rosetta mission that was launched in
2004 got to the comet I think you'd see
in the next slide and 20th 2014 and has
landed there and it's kind of work now
our big offworld language archive that's
sitting on that come
so we have a world language archive
sitting on a comet yeah and in the
comments you know keep coming back
around the Sun so I think there'll be
something that we likely keep revisiting
it's just an interesting clock in and of
itself it's great just in case a
extra-terrestrial II there are assets as
well as just the case okay so then the
clock of the long now yeah alright so
the ten thousand year clock this is a
difficult thing to actually be able to
make the next the next slide shows kind
of one of the difficulties yeah I mean
we it's a you know on some level it's a
material science problem and some level
it's a mechanic's problem at the largest
level it's really just kind of a it's a
it's an art project that we're trying to
not only engineer to a high level so
that it actually works and has a chance
of working for 10,000 years but also
captures people's imagination is
interesting like if we just made
something that nobody could touch and
and was locked in a nitrogen environment
that would be the easiest solution for
us as engineers but it doesn't actually
change the way people think so a lot of
what we do is is these in a way kind of
theatrical engineering but it's all it's
very grounded and you know what could
actually work but it as an example of
one of the problems that the clock has
that we had to solve the clock keeps
both solar time what's called solar time
and absolute time and so it keeps solar
time and that's how it keeps
synchronized and doesn't drift over time
it has a part at the very top of the
mountain that heats up and a bellows of
air expands and we get a mechanical
trigger that says this is solar noon hmm
but since the clock also has a pendulum
that's keeping kind of day to day what's
called absolute time or we can call it
clock time that is much more regular
than the sun's motions or parent motions
because we're not a perfect circle as we
go around the Sun so that plus or minus
15-minute difference is called the
equation of time and and we need to
account for that is we're going to
synchronize the clock to solar noon to
be absolute nit but
if you can kind of move through the next
couple slides as I talk here that the
the earth is also wobbling on its axis
every twenty five thousand seven hundred
ninety-two years and it's slowing its
rotational rate by about a second a
century right now and that actually can
change with climate change by how much
ice is at the poles and then but and all
of that had to get wrapped up into a
mechanical part of the clock called the
equation of time cam which is that
equation of time as it changes over ten
thousand years we left a little bit at
the top and bottom so this is a twelve
thousand year cam so you have a thousand
years to make your new one before you
run out of time so that's just an
example it's kind of free engineering
betting two we end up yeah going down
with the clock it holds both absolute
time and solar time and you have a
mechanism for every time its solar noon
it's gonna expand air and cause another
yes one mechanism it just repeats that
every after every time Tyler said
there's a enough so thermal difference
to make it happen and then the shape of
this over 12,000 years accounts for the
precession cycle as well as slowing
slowing we both in one mechanism yeah
and the equation of time itself
that is mostly repeating but evolving
over that time
but that twist that you see in it for
instance is the it's the largely that
the processional cycle in them
this is a massively complex like
engineering feat for something as simple
as oh yeah meet me here at 6 p.m. yeah
yeah you know it doesn't even really
have our dials it's mostly astronomic
dials and shows you you know the current
night sky and Sun and the moon stars and
so yeah it's time that matters over this
kind of time scale it's not you know
it's not an atomic clock that's meant to
divide seconds into nanoseconds and
picoseconds but just a reference and and
you know back to the beginning of our
discussion one of the design principles
that we always kind of look at is like
you know if we had dug into this
mountain and found the clock already
they're like what do we wish we had
found and and so you know what you kind
of you you want to have had those past
generations care about you right like
and that's that's a rarity that you even
with things like Stonehenge or the
pyramids there's not much sense from
those objects that those people cared
about the people 5,000 years ago that
continued to appreciate their assets and
so hopefully if we do the clock right
people will feel will feel that love I
love that that's so good
what do you want past generations to
care about you in the future yeah how do
you want them to show their care and if
you do the clock right you show the care
that you spent a good amount of time
investing into making sure that it was
right the next asset shows West Texas
the actual location
yeah we're now building the clock at
full scale that Monument scale it's 500
feet of vertical boring through a
mountain and several thousand feet of
tunnels that have been put in and this
is the kind of journey part where you
hike from the valley floor and you enter
into the bottom of the site and you come
up through the whole clock and then you
exit out at the top and hike back down
to that to the valley floor is this kind
of experience design of the whole thing
okay so you're gonna the park in the
valley hike up and then you're gonna go
down to the clock and no you go up
through the closet enter the model enter
at the bottom and and and you like
through the clock yeah so it's kind of
architecture
all around and then at the top do you
kind of like see like the clocks actual
there's no one place you can see all of
the clock it's a it's an underground
space but there's a place where the
dials are and then but I think that you
know the real reward when you come out
at the top is you've been underground
for a long time and you get this amazing
desert you know 360 view and I think
really even just you know hanging out in
the high desert with your friends is
kind of one of the best slowing down
activities that you can have you know if
we if if kind of coming to visit the
clock it's you could do just that it's a
great and if they you appreciate the
clock part I think that's also great you
know a few slides on some of the
mechanisms here and how the clock works
and basically the clock works just like
any other clock where it's got a power
system and a governor it has chimes I
think one of the more unique parts of
the clock is this part that it has a
synchronizer to the Sun and in our case
the chimes themselves also it was a
algorithm that Danny Hillis devised
worked with brian eno on it to ring the
series of ten bells within the clock in
a different sequence each day for ten
thousand years so the the week it's over
three and a half million permutations so
every time you were there and the bells
ring it's kind of the unique moment that
you have with the clock that doesn't
repeat that that last slide just kind of
going back to the materials and plugins
really most of the materials in the
clock I'll go back are yeah are things
like stainless steel special grades of
stainless steel and titanium which can
last on these kind of timescales but one
of the unsolved problems that we had was
was bearings which is the part that
allows a rolling thing to roll in any
mechanism in your car or whatever and
when I started this project 20 years ago
there was the perfect bearing had been
invented it was these all ceramic
bearings and they were invented for
satellites in aerospace use and they
were designed to use it you know no
lubrication and operate in space near
Diamond hard ceramics but they're like
50,000 dollars each and we're gonna use
thousands of them and so it never seemed
to make sense but over the last 20 years
they become much more commonplace and
now they're in like rollerblades and
fidgets spinners and they cost ten
dollars and
luckily the kind of development cycle of
the ceramic bearing really opened up the
chance for us to be able to use it
within the clock and so this is New
York's area but one of those looks like
yep and there's just a few slides of
just some of the most recent
installation work and some of these sir
just stills from videos that that you
may have seen of a clock being installed
and I'm gonna be walking through this
yes as spiral staircase that that that
was cut into the earth or into the solid
rock we built a thirty six thousand
pound diamond chainsaw robot that ran
for two years straight just cutting
spiral stairs and that's that way that
humans kind of walk through the whole
clock
this is great we have something tip we
can look at in the future yeah while we
destroy ourselves now thanks for doing
what you do this is the type of thing
where you're you're you're building
something so that future generations can
look back and say I'm glad they thought
of us I'm glad they wanted to take the
time to to slow down like this yeah it's
it's just as much about the present as
it is about the future so like hopefully
if we do our job right and the thing
doesn't get destroyed and and it makes
it and it's engineered correctly that's
great but also I think it's it's
important that we as in our present have
and have a have a way to talk and an
excuse to talk about this feature and
and even if somebody you know decides
that they want to tell us why this won't
work they are they they are engaging in
a millennium multi millennial future by
just telling us why it won't work right
so you know it's a it's a if you didn't
have that object to evoke that
conversation if you just wrote a white
paper it doesn't really change the
conversation and it doesn't it doesn't
allow new stories to be told and I think
the only thing that we know it that has
lasted on this timescale is stories and
myths and if we can if we can in a small
way you know spark new versions of that
where people are thinking about the
future in a different way that's that's
really our hope yeah
and then so we're thinking on a time
scale of completion to for people to
actually be able to walk through it when
we don't have a completion date we have
been you know we're we're definitely you
know further along than we have been in
ages and we're I think the the
installation pastes been amazing for us
because we've been working on these
things for so long and so it feels a lot
closer but we purposefully aren't
working towards that towards relation
you know towards the completion table we
want to make sure it's right more than
make you know saying a certain date that
we either hit or don't hit yeah yeah but
hopefully the kids born today will be
able to do something like yeah one
reverse 301 hopes yeah and then so long
now does seminars locally in the Bay
Area these long-term thinking seminars
locally in once a month what we have to
series we do one at the interval which
is that our kind of cafe and bar and
headquarters and and that's more salon
style we do one to two a month there and
then we do the the series that we
started way back in 2003 that Stuart
brand has been curating all these years
that is once a month in us has done in
larger venues from 750 to 1500 seats but
actually the largest audience is our
online audience is the podcast audience
we get somewhere around you know fifty
to a hundred thousand downloads a month
of of that and so people that's that's
become the largest kind of way that
people find out about long now because
it'll be it'll be a speaker that they
want to hear and they go well what about
who are these other speakers and and and
and that's led into our membership
program that's had over 10,000 people
sign up and it's kind of become the
community that the the focusing point
for where the community of long now
hangs out and then the interval which as
I mentioned is the cafe and bar that we
we opened up as part of our headquarters
and it's also kind of a museum it's also
a library and
we designed it specifically around
having a good place for conversations
and as a welcoming place to have
conversations that you wouldn't normally
have and so I think it's generally been
successful in that it kind of people
come there to
to meet interesting other people as well
as just connect you know it's not a loud
bar or co-working cafe where no one's
supposed to be talking to each other and
it's kind of a different vibe and 10,000
members now have signed up for long now
membership 50 to 100 thousand downloads
a month on the podcast there's some big
numbers these are excellent things yeah
I mean we thought we were we didn't
think that there was much popularity and
some of these concepts but it certainly
resonates with some people yeah yeah and
then I want to see Xander what are your
thoughts on on this kind of like this
geopolitical climate that we're in with
8 billion of us now exponential
technologies roaring what do you think
is needed most to inspire us towards
that unity that we come from I think I
don't know that I'm qualified to say
what's actually in a unified the world
but I mean I think you know there's
certainly some things that could occur
that could do that something like you
know contacting extraterrestrial
intelligence or a threat of something
like a asteroid or a comet I would hate
to think that that's the only way that
it can happen but you know I think the
pendulum swings through these kind of
climates and we see through history that
that has happened and I think we're
watching them swing as we speak
I think the difference now is that we've
were more interconnected than we ever
have been I think that's the most unique
thing of our time you often read about
you know times of great change in the
past and they kind of have a lot of
those writings have very similar vibes
to what we we hear now about you know
this ex technology or this new thing is
going to ruin you you know is that our
parents generation it was rock and roll
and my generation was the first video
games now and says kids are having too
much screen time and I guarantee when
those kids grow up they're gonna be just
fine and they're you know they're just
they're just adapting to the new
technology and we look at it and it
looks weird right so I think I think
those are the kind of things that that
don't really matter over time and even
swings in
liberalism or conservatism and we've
seen that happen with McCarthy and
Japanese internment and and so there's
gonna be darker and lighter times and
but I think in general things are moving
in him always in a better way yeah yeah
the outboard spiral of I don't think
anyone would trade like being alive a
hundred years ago with no penicillin and
dentistry I don't buy it
to go visit maybe for a week and then
come the good old days concept I think
doesn't really look that work there's
smell or something also yeah profound to
just go visit for smaller periods maybe
yeah we're like those that may have been
more spiritually connected at the time
potentially thousands of years ago maybe
yeah I mean I think that's a it's an
interesting one is that I think people
probably I mean definitely were more
religious and definitely were in a way I
don't know where you want to put that in
this energy but when there was no TV
made you know take them to do that and
the pyramids and Taj Mahal like I mean
what this is like thousands of humans
and and in in decades of construction
and materials that were we didn't have
these big like trucks and stuff to carry
them there so it's like the ingenuity
and just like in focus I think is
actually the bulk the the amazing thing
and I think that's in I've seen many of
these documentary efforts where people
have tried to you know recreate certain
things where you know those aliens or
lasers or all these things it's like
actually you can use old technologies to
make every single one of these things
but in every single one of those kind of
case studies that I've looked at the
hardest thing was really just the human
organization part and that was one you
know we have like alarm clocks and cell
phones and radios now like then they
were trying to coordinate efforts like
the pyramids with none of that and
actually the human coordination effort
in focus it was the real that was the
real amazing thing that they had but you
know I mean we're yeah
Sagrada família is still being built
it's decades in centuries and we're two
decades into our project so I mean we
can still do these things that's not
impossible yeah yeah and they inspire
long-term thinking that's massive two
quick questions on the way out for ease
and ER first question is do you think
simulation I do not think where is it
tell us why I just find it it's almost
too easy of a of a answer I think the
it's almost like the you know is there
an afterlife thing it's like it makes us
feel better it makes maybe more control
that there's something more than then we
know and I think that nature and the
world and the universe is way more
complex and we should give it credit for
that and then what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world
Wow my daughter is definitely the most
beautiful thing
no why just watching a human boot up and
he you know both how little how much is
skin coated and how much is is is what
you think you are gonna have control
over and how you don't and yeah and I
think that's that's the most beautiful
thing yeah
Xander this isn't such an epic episode
on long-term thinking thank you
absolutely thank you for coming on yeah
yeah I feel very enlightened I do I feel
like we can build projects that inspire
long-term thinking and that in itself is
just what our answer says I think would
want us to do for the future yeah
hopefully I love it
I love it thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking also share more content like
this with your friends families
co-workers people online on social media
get talking about long-term thinking
about things like the Rosetta project
the the 10,000 year clock really talk
more about these things inspire
long-term thinking check out the links
in the bio below too long now dork also
the interval org and the Twitter pages
we've joined them as members download
their podcast get rolling as well in
that front shout out to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ronnie and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the organization's
communities around the world that you
live in support them help them grow
support simulation our links are below
to our patreon or cryptocurrency link
our PayPal link also our link to design
cool merch like this shirt and get paid
for doing that and also to spread
thought-provoking questions go and build
the future everyone manifest your dream
since the world thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon peace